el activista y filántropo turco osman
cábala acaba de ser condenado a cadena
perpetua revisable por el alto tribunal
de juicios penales en estambul por
supuestamente haber intentado derrocar
el gobierno turco en 2013 durante las
protestas de que si el filántropo es
acusado de ser un instigador y
financiador de estas protestas algo que
según varios organismos internacionales
es completamente falso y se acusa que
durante esas protestas que fueron
multitudinarias en el centro de estambul
y donde murieron ocho personas a cova
cavada estuvo detrás de esta acción el
tribunal europeo derechos humanos
durante los cuatro años y medio largos
de detención preventiva de este
activista ha decretado su libertad
incondicional explicando que el juicio
que estaba teniendo lugar en turquía era
aparte de ilegal completamente nulo a
turquía no ha acatado esta decisión sino
que ha condenado a acabada y por lo
tanto ahora mismo entra en un proceso
sancionador dentro del consejo de europa
por no haber acatado una alta decisión
de un alto tribunal europeo este proceso
sancionador podría acabar al cabo de
unos años
con la expulsión de turquía de este
órgano internacional el consejo de
europa que no es parte de la europea
sino que es mucho más amplio y entre los
que hay también otros países fuera del
ámbito europeo como turquía antes rusia
bielorrusia y también surgió